منظمه حقوقيه ايرانيه تكشف ان 109
متظاهرين مهددون باصدار او تنفيذ احكام
بالاعدام
زليسك يقول ان القوات الاوكرانيه صامده
امام هجمات اكثر شده على سوليدار في شرق
اوكرانيا
حفظا ليبحث في القاهره مع مسؤولينا مصريين
وضع خريطه طريق لتوحيد المؤسسه العسكريه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الى فتره الاخباريه
جديده من العربيه نبداوها بهذه النشره
اعلنت منظمه حقوق الانسان الايرانيه انه
لا يزال 109 متظاهرين على الاقل معرضين
لخطر اصدار او تنفيذ احكام بالاعدام في
ايران واكدت المنظمه الحقوقيه الايرانيه
ومقرها النرويج في احدث تقرير لها ان
النظام الايراني يحاول متعمدا اشاعه
الغموض حول قضايا المعتقلين عبر تصريحات
متناقضه في ملفاتهم وخاصه المحكوم عليهم
بالاعدام وادعت منظمه المجتمع المدني
الايراني والدولي الى تسليط الضوء على
القمع المكثف للنظام الايراني اثناء
الاحتجاز والاستجواب واصدار احكام جماعيه
هذا هو عبر المستشار الامن القومي
الامريكي جيكسوربان عن ادانه بلاده لاعدام
محمد مهدي كرمي ومحمد حسين في ايران
واعلان طهران عن المزيد من احكام الاعدام
ودع صلب على النظام الايراني الى وقع
عمليات الاعدام فورا ملوحا بمحاسبه ايران
على سلوكها
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
سلام
[موسيقى]
وكانت حكومات بريطانيا وفرنسا وبلجيكا
والنرويج والدنمارك وهولندا انتقد سياسه
اعدام المحتجين التي تنتجها ايران وقررت
استدعاء السفراء طهران وزيره الخارجيه
الالمانيه اعتبرت ان النظام الذي يقتل
الشباب لترويع الشعب لا مستقبل له مضيفه
ان بلادها طلبت من السفير الايراني في
برلين تقديم توضيحات بشارع عمليات الاعدام
والقمع بحق الايرانيين
الذي يتم بموجبه تنفيذ العقوبات والادراج
من ضمنها طلبته اليوم من السفير الايراني
الحضور الى وزاره الخارجيه من اجل توضيح
لا لبس فيه حول القمع والترويع الذين
يتعرض لهم الايرانيون وكذلك عمليتي
الاعدام الاخيرتين واللتين سيكون لهما
عواقب
نزيف الاعدامات متواصل في ايران
ثلاثه اشخاص ينضمون الى لائحه المحكوم
عليهم بالاعدام
ليصل العدد الاجمالي الى 17 شخصا
تم تنفيذ اربعه منها لحد الان
محسن شكاري
[موسيقى]
محمد مهدي كرامي
فتح حسيني
جميع الذين تم اعدامهم اتوهموا بقتل اعضاء
من رجال الامن
المحكمه العليا صادقت على حكمين اخرين
ينتظران تنفيذ فقط
[موسيقى]
الشرطي قتل في مكان اخر حسب موقع الشرطه
نفسه اي انه قتل في مدينه الرباط كريم
ولكن نسبه الى ملف ابني هذا ما ذكره موقع
الشرطه عندما كان الشرطي ملقا على الارض
ركله الناس الا انهم نسبوه الى ملف ابني
حتى يعدموه كما قال الخطيب في يوم تشيع
جثمان القتيل كرمبور بانهم تجمعوا عليه
هنا وقتلوه هنا ما يعني انه قتل خلال
اشتباك وليس نتيجه لدعسه بسياره الجميع
يعلم ذلك لكن تعمدوا ان ينسبوه الى ملف
ابنه ليشنقه هؤلاء يمارسون الظلمه انهم
ظلمه
[تصفيق]
وتمت لجنه العلاقات الخارجيه في مجلس
الشيوخ الامريكي النظام الايراني بانه
متواطئ في تمكين روسيا من الهجوم على
المدنيين في اوكرانيا وقالت اللجنه عبر
حسابها على تويتر ان النظام الايراني يقتل
شعبه في الداخل مشيره الى انه لا يعنيه اي
شيء سوى استمرار
نفا المتحدث الرسمي باسم وزاره الخارجيه
الامريكيه نتريس حديثا للعربيه اي اختلاف
في الموقف بين بلاده واسرائيل بشان ايران
واكد في ربه للعربيه ان هناك اجماعا بين
الطرفين بعدم السماح الايران من تلك اسلحه
النوويه
على المستوى الاستراتيجي هناك اجماع مطلق
وهناك اجماع مطلق مع شركائنا الاسرائيليين
كلانا ملتزم تماما بحقيقه ان ايران يجب ان
لا تكون ابدا قادره على امتلاك سلاح
النووي هذا هو التزام الرئيس بيض هذا هو
نفسه الالتزام الذي سمعناه من رئيس
الوزراء نتنياهو انه بالمناسبه نفس
الالتزام الذي سمعناه من نتنياه واسلافه
لذا فنحن على قدم وساق عندما يتعلق الامر
بهذا الهدف الاستراتيجي ليس هناك سر وقد
البحر سلفا الى انه عندما يتعلق الامر
لكيفيه القيام بذلك فقد تكون هناك بعض
الاختلافات التكتيكيه هناك بعض الاختلافات
التكتيكيه نحن لم نخفي ذلك لدينا علاقه
وثيقه مع اسرائيل بما يكفي
بما يكفي للسماح لنا باجراء محادثات صريحه
وعندما نختلف مختلف نقول لهم ما نفكر فيه
وهم بالتاكيد لا يخجلون من اخبارنا بما
يفكرون فيه نحن نؤمن بان الدبلوماسيه هي
الوسيله الاكثر قابليه للتطبيق والاستدامه
لمنع ايران بشكل دائم وقابل للتحقق من
الحصول على سلاح النووي لكننا نتفق ايضا
مع شركائنا الاسرائيليين على انه لا ينبغي
لنا ازاله اي شيء من على الطاوله نحن لم
ناخذ اي شيء من على الطاوله
وفي رده على سؤال العربيه حول مائده عادت
ايران مستقبلا وقالت انها على استعداد
اللسانها في المحادثات استبعد اند برايس
ترحيب الجانب الامريكي بهذه الخطوه لان
ايران لا يمكن تصديقها كما قال
بعد دبلوماسيه لكن في ظل عدم وجود اي
اهتمام حقيقي بالدبلوماسيه من جانب
الايرانيين سنواصل تركيزنا على دعم الشعب
الايراني مع استمرار تركيزنا على مواجهه
المساعده الامنيه الايرانيه لروسيا
والى التطورات الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه
قال رئيس الاوكرانيه
هجمات جديده واكثر شده على سوليدار قرب
مدينه بخموت في شرق البلاد التي تحاول
موسكو السيطره عليها منذ اشهر
الجديده والاكثر صرامه
كامله هناك
وكان الجيش الروسيه قصف الامدادات
العسكريه الاوكرانيه المتجهه من مدينه
بخموت الى بلده سوليدار وفي حصيله اوليه
قتل العشرات من الجنود الاوكرانيين خلال
القصر المستمر على الطريق السريع بين
مخموط وسوليدار
بصفوف القوات الاوكرانيه على خط التماس في
سياق القتال المضاد البطاريه في دونيتك تم
تدمير محطتين رادار امريكيه الصنع وايضا
تدمير نظام امريكي صنع في لوجان
[تصفيق]
وبينما تستعر المعارك في الشرق الاوكرانيه
تستعد كييف لتلقي دعم العسكري نوعين من
بريطانيا حيث نقلت وسائل الاعلام
البريطانيه دراسه الحكومه لارسال دبابات
بريطانيه الى اوكرانيا لاول مره منذ ضلع
الحرب وافدت المصادر بان لندن تدرس ارسال
10 دبابات من طرازه تشالنجر 2 على امل ان
يدفع ذلك الحلفاء لان يحذوا حذوها وتعتبر
ترنجر 2 الدبابه القتاليه الرئيسيه في
الجيش البريطاني وتتمكن من اصابه ثمانيه
اهداف مختلفه في الدقيقه الواحده كما
تتميز بنظام الالكترونيه للتحكمي بنيران
فاصله قصيره بعده هذه النشره
لدينا رئيس حكومه كردستان العراق يعلن
واحباطه مخططين لتنفيذ تفجيرات في اربيل
واعتقال اربعه من داعش
نوصلوا مع حضراتكم تقديم هذه النشره اجرى
قائد الجيش الوطني الليبيه خليفه حفتر في
القاهره محادثات مع مسؤولين مصريين لوضع
خريطه الطريق لتوحيد المؤسسين العسكريه
والامنيه وشملت المحادثات التاكيده على
ضروره حصر السلاح بشكل كامل وتفكيك
الميليشيا المسلحه بشكل عاجل ووضع الخطط
لتامين البلاد لتسهيل عمليه الانتخابات
واي استفتاء المرتقب على الدستور حفتر طلب
بضروره وجود حشد دولي لوقف وصول الاسلحه
الى الميليشيا لضمان نجاح خطه تفكيك
الميليشيا وحصري اسلحتها
على تشكيل لجنه امنيه عسكريه تضع خطه لدمج
العناصر المسلحه التابعه للمليشيا في
الجيش الليبي
ليبيا ايضا ان تستمر فعاليات اليوم الثاني
للملتقى التحضيري لمؤتمر المصالحه الوطنيه
الذي يشرف عليه المجلس الرئاسي الليبي
برعايه من الاتحاد الافريقي
سياسي لمحاوله فك جمودي لازمه السياسيه
الليبيه وفي هذا المكان يجتمع ممثلين عن
جميع اطياف القوه السياسيه الليبيه بما
فيهم ممثلين عن سيف الاسلام القذافي
لمحاولته وضعته صحيحه لملف المصالحه
الليبيه
اكثر من 100 شخص حظروا هذه الاجتماعات بعد
تقسيمهم الى ست مجموعات لوضع الاطر
الاساسيه في مشروع المصالحه الوطنيه
جلسات تستمر حتى نهايه الاسبوع
من القضايا الجوهريه في مسار المصالحه على
سبيل المثال مسار العداله الانتقاليه شكل
العداله الانتقاليه التعامل مع المركزيه
وعدد اخر من القضايا الجوهريه المتصله
بالمصالحه
الشائكه في اعتراض ممثل سيف الاسلام
القذافي ورصدهم المشاركه في فعاليات اليوم
الاول بسبب وجود العالم والافتتاح بالنشيد
هكر صفوه الاجتماعات
[موسيقى]
الاطراف التي لربما لديها بعض الملاحظات
انا اؤمن فيهم دورهم الكبير ودورهم المهم
في نجاح هذا المشروع الوطني وكما قلت
هذا المشروع هو مفتاح الحل للعمليه
السياسيه في ليبيا
وتجاوز
النقاط الخلافيه ومعالجه النقاط الخلافيه
لابد ان تكون عبر حوار وطني شامل وهو ما
نعمل عليه الان ما يميز هذا الملتقى
اقامته على ارض الليبيه وبحضور مندوبين عن
جميع الفئات مما يجعله نتائجها اكثر قبولا
للتطبيق على ارض الواقع منير الاشهب
طرابلس العربيه
اعلى جهاز مكافحه الارهاب في اقليم
كردستان
بشبكتين ارهابيتين على علاقه بتنظيم داعش
كانت بسطه التنفيذ تفجيرات وهجمات ارهابيه
بالعاصمه اربيل راس السنه واكد مجلس امن
اقليم كردستان في بيان القاء القبض على
اربعه اشخاص كانوا ضمن شبكتين ويعملون
بامر من قبل قيادات تنظيم داعش
اهلا وزير الحج والعمره السعوديه توفيق
الربيعه ان حج هذا العام سيكون بنفس العدد
قبل جائحه كورونا مؤكدا عوده الحج من دون
قيود او شروط واوضح الربيعه ان الحج لن
يشترط فيه هذا العام حد للعمره
الاولى
عوده اعداد الحجاج الى ما كانت عليه قبل
الجايحه وبدون اي طيور على العمر
البشرى الاخرى انه من المتعارف عليه
والعشرات السنين ان كلي بعثه من اي دوله
في العالم عاده ترتبط بمؤسسه خدمات واحده
وتكون تعمل معها في خدمات الحج
ولتعزيز التنافسيه
وتطوير الخدمات وتعزيز الان وابتداء من
هذا العام اي بعثه حج اي مكتب حج من اي
مكان في العالم يستطيع التعاقد مع اي شركه
مرخصه تحقق المتطلبات اللي يحتاجها حجاج
هذه الدوله
وحسب اخر احصائيه رسميه قبل جاء احد
كورونا فقد وصل عدد الحجاج لعام 2019 الى
نحو مليونين و500000 حج منهم اكثر من
مليون و 800 الف حج من خارج السعوديه
وكانت المملكه تتخذت اجراءات احترازيه
خلصت بموجبها عدد الحجاج اثناء جائت
كورونا وفي العام الماضي رفعت الاعداد الى
مليون حاجه من داخل السعوديه وخارجها
لكنها فرضت شروط من بينها الا يكون الحاج
قد تجاوز 65 عاما مع اشتراط استكمال
التحصين بالجرعات الاساسيه بلقاحنا
وائل ازمه النقابات في بريطانيا ما خرج من
الاجتماع بين الحكومه البريطانيه وقاده
النقابات في قطاعات الصحه والتعليم
في معتبرته نقابه الممرضين مخيبا للامال
بانتظار ان تستكمل بقيه المحادثات على امل
التوصل لحل يرضي الحكومه والمدربين معا
وهو ما لم يستبعده مفاوضون في المرحله
المقبله
اجتماعو طال انتظاره بين وزير الصحه
استقبالي ومسؤولي نقابه الصحه لحل نزاع
اضرابات اعضائها بسبب الاجور اجتماع حمل
امال التجنب المزيد من الاضطرابات في
خدمات الصحه الوطنيه التي تعاني من ضغط
شديد غير مسبوق وسط التكهن بسداد دفعه
نقديه لمره واحده الى المطربين ترتبط
بالانتاجيه
ان المحادثات جاريه وفيما يتعلق بالدفع
يجب ان يجري تلك المحادثات على اساس ما هو
في متناول الجميع وما هو معقول
لكن يبدو ان هذه المفاوضات التعثرت في اول
اجتماع بين الطرفين بحسب مسؤول النقابه
لانهاء موجه الاضرابات
الحكومه فرصه اخرى لتصحيح هذا الامر لقد
جئنا الى هنا بحسن نيه ما يريدون التحدث
عنه والانتاجيه عندما يعمل اعضاءنا لمده
18 ساعه كيف يمكنك ان تصبح اكثر انتاجيه
لا اعرف
شهر يناير عاده ما تكون فيه خدمات الصحه
الوطنيه تحت ضغط كبير بسبب الامراض
الشتويه المتزايده الى جانب معالجه
الامراض الاخرى وخصوصا انقطاع الصحه بحاجه
الى ملئ اكثر من 130,000 وظيفه فيما اعلنت
وزاره الصحه انها ستنقل الاف المرضى الى
دور الرعايه لتوفير المزيد من الاسره في
المستشفيات
فشل المفاوضه بين الحكومه والنقابه يعيد
جدوله اضراباته في قطاع الصحه بدءا من هذا
الاسبوع وقد تكون الاكبر على الاطلاق التي
تشهده بريطانيا وفقا النقابه اذا لم يحصل
اعضائها على زياده اجرهم تعكس غلاء
المعيشه مصطفى زارو العربيه لندن
في بريطانيا
من البريطانيين تخلوا عن جنسيتهم منذ خروج
المملكه المتحده من الاتحاد الاوروبي
[موسيقى]
نجحت طالبتان هنادي وجيهان من فتيات
مديريه حريب جنوب مارب في كسر الصوره
النمطيه عن الفتاه المغربيه
واستطاعتها دخول مجال الفن التشكيلي من
اوسع ابوابه وذلك برسم لوحات تشكيليه
مبهره باستخدام الخيط والابره في اسلوب
جديد في الرسم في اليمن
هنادي وجيهان قصه شغف ارتبطت بالرسم
تحاولتا بكل جهد ان تصبح من المتميزات في
مجتمع ماربي محافظه اريد له ان يكون مغلقا
بدون فرشاه او معجون الالوان التي تستخدم
في هذا الرسم بل بالابره والخيط تمكنت من
صناعه لوحات فنيه غير تقليديه
اختلفنا من جهه اللون بعد تفكير واتفاق
اتفاق اتمنى اللون الاسود والابيض لتعاكس
الالوان
رسمناها في تقريبا في تسع ساعات الدكتور
عبد العزيز المقالح عرضناها شفنا اقبال
كبير من الجمهور اعجب بها طلبوا منها
الرسمات مختلفه من مديريه حريب جنوبيه
مارب حضر الكثير من المبدعين في مجالات
شتى وحضرت هنادي وجهان بفن تشكيلي جديد
ولان معرضه معرفه الثاني للكتاب كان نافذه
ثقافيه وابداعيه على العالم فقد كان ايضا
بوابتهما للشهره من خلال اللوحات
والرسومات التي لاقت رواجن كبيره حيث بدات
بشخصيه المعرض واديب اليمن الراحل عبد
العزيز
المقالحه وحسينا احنا كمان فخر وكان في
اقبال كثير من الناس علينا والحمد لله
طب باقي انا اول تجربه شخصيه مشهوره
والحمد لله ضبطت معنا
وبعدين جربنا الثاني تجربه بعدين قلنا
بدنا نفتح انا وهي محل الكتروني المتجر
الالكتروني يعني مفتوح وان شاء الله نحصل
اجبار من الاشخاص
ماربوا ارضوا الحضاره والتاريخ بموروثها
ومخزنها الانسانيه والاثري الشامل هي
المشروع القادم لفتياتها المبدعات في متجر
الكتروني كان فكره وصار بعدها هذا الاقبال
جاهزا لطلب اللوحات الفنيه محمود الحميدي
العربيه مارب
رئيس الامريكيه وبعدين حاله الطوارئ في
كاليفورنيا بسبب عواطف انت سبب في مقتل 12
شخص على الاقل خلال الايام العشره الماضيه
بالاضافه الى انقطاع الكهرباء عن اكثر من
120000 منزل وشركه من جانبها اصدرت ولايه
كاليفورنيا اوامره اجلاء ونداءات تحذير
بسبب العاصفه الشديده
العاصمه الهنديه نيودلهي اصبحت امس غارقه
في الضباب التلوث الشديد مع موجه برد
اجبرا السلطات على تاجيل المدارس وايضا
تاجيل العديد من الرحلات الجويه وتتوقع
اداره الارصاد الهنديه ان يستمر الضباب
الكفيف في اجزاء كثيره من نيوزله
والولايات الشماليه والشرقيه حتى يوم غدا
[موسيقى]
العناوين
منظمه حقوقيه ايرانيه تكشف ان 109
متظاهرين مهددون باصدار او تنفيذ احكام
بالاعدام
قوه الاوكرانيه الصامده امام هجمات اكثر
شده على سوليدار في شرق اوكرانيا
مع مسؤولين مصريين وضع خريطه طريق لتوحيد
المؤسسه العسكريه في ليبيا
نلتقي بعد قليل الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]